good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
director of the long now foundation as
many of you know we start these out with
a thing called the long short a short
film that exemplifies long-term thinking
um tonight's long short is by Tom Lowe
who I think we've shown some of his work
before he has a website called time
escapes org where he's taking some of
the I think some of the greatest
time-lapse photography going and for
tonight we found a really great
selection of his of mostly Bristlecone
pine forests some of the and you'll be
seeing some of those same for us I
believe he shot in the White Mountains
where Rachel shot these four to five
thousand year old trees and he did it in
a time-lapse along with some pieces of
Yosemite and the Very Large Array where
they're listening for aliens so enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Stuart brand from a long now
foundation you know the long now
foundation is building a 10,000 year
clock and we're so pleased and proud to
be building something that can tick for
10,000 years and then we find out from
Rachael and others that what a few
things been ticking kind of time and
we're just trying to catch up to them
like she's further proof that field
biologists have more fun than anybody
and the question you might ask yourself
as you know I'm a kind of a fan of
genetic engineering and synthetic
biology as you watch these various
species go by think about which ones you
might like to have some genes from to
blend into your germline so your
children and grandchildren might be part
allof tree or something
Rachael Sussman
[Applause]
hello thank you it's such an honor to be
here and such a great audience alone now
so for the past five years I've been
researching working with biologists and
traveling all over the world to
photograph continuously living organisms
that are 2,000 years old and older so
the project is part fine art my
background is as a fine artist it's part
science there are philosophical elements
and a strong environmental component and
as you can see there's a lot of thinking
in a lot of different areas happening
and I put together a little mind map but
the primary reason that I'm here this
evening is because at its core this work
really is about long-term thinking and
I'm trying to provide a means in which
for us to step outside of our quotidian
experience of time and start to consider
a deeper timescale so my idea for this
project was to start at year 0 and work
backward from there and then in terms of
scope I'm trying to find a
representative sample of every species
that's met the 2,000 year mark so before
I dig into the work I'm going to show
you a lot of images this evening I just
wanted to take a quick moment to talk
about art and science and my particular
relationship with it so I depend upon
scientific research in order to be as
accurate as possible in terms of dating
these organisms so the science is
basically supporting my work in some
cases I've found that the research
actually hasn't been done yet or is
incomplete so that was actually really
surprising for me so this project has
actually never been done before in the
arts or the sciences now there isn't
actually an area of study that deals
with this global species longevity which
is a term that I've made up basically
but in part it's because the subject
matter is too broad so wrote scientific
inquiry is ever specializing which means
that sometimes you're going to miss the
forest for the trees so this evening I'm
gonna ask you to travel back in time
with me and I'm what we're gonna start a
2,000 years and work our
back and I actually haven't walked
through the work chronologically before
so I thought that was appropriate for
long now this is a brain coral it's the
oldest brain known brain coral in the
world and it lives in Tobago at about 60
feet depths and it's about 18 feet
across so it's pretty big and I first
found out about this through a scientist
in London who was just having a casual
conversation with who happened to have
gone on vacation to Tobago and suggested
that I check it out so the age of this
of this coral is estimated based on its
size and its annual growth and there are
a couple other corals that are part of
the project that I've been photographed
yet ones in Hawaii and one is in the
frigid waters off of Scandinavia and
those actually both require submersible
pods in order to reach them so I hope I
get there but corals are actually the
only animals in the project so we say
goodbye to the animals so this is a bail
Bab tree when I was in 2007 I had the
opportunity to travel around the Limpopo
Province in South Africa with a woman
who's an expert in Bay o Bab trees and
she was doing research for for a book
and I had started emailing some people
and asked if anybody knew about the
Bayeux Babs and through a series of
connections I ended up at her doorstep
in Johannesburg and we went on a little
road trip so what she was doing was
actually measuring the trees their
height and their girth and has been
looking at that data over an extended
period of time
but the bay Oh Babs are actually
notoriously hard to date because they
get pulpy at their centres but I'll get
back to that in a minute this one is
actually in the Kruger Game Preserve so
if you want to visit this tree you
actually need special permission and an
armed escort but thankfully that didn't
prove necessary and that's for lions and
tigers and bears
this is another babe they're about four
in this region that are thought to be
around the 2,000 year range and it was
winter so the babe apps are deciduous
and it's so during the rainy season they
actually would be full of leaves but
then he wouldn't see this beautiful
structure now this tree lives on a
private farm and it was actually struck
by lightning many many years ago and it
was knocked on its side and half of it
was uprooted but those exposed roots
were transformed into branches so it's
actually one of the more symmetrical
beoh babs that you'll see and this is
the segolia Bayeux bab which is most
likely the oldest in the group and you
know I think of all of these organisms
as palimpsests so not so much like
layers of text on an ancient parchment
although the street does have names
carved into its trunk but I'm referring
to the secondary definition where a
thing contains its own history within
itself so all of these organisms contain
thousands of years of their own
histories not to mention clues about
climate and human activity
so the Bay of ebbs I mentioned get very
tend to get pulpy at their centers as
they get older so this can this can
serve as a natural shelter for animals
but has also been appropriated for a
number of dubious human uses including a
toilet a prison and even a bar inside
one of these babe trees also in Africa
this is the well which eeeh which is the
national plant of Namibia and the well
which iya is only found in parts of
coastal Namibia and Angola and where
it's perfectly adapted to get almost all
of its moisture from mist coming off of
the sea and strangely enough the well
which is actually a tree and if you see
right there it's actually bearing cones
it's a conifer so it's a very primitive
conifer in the Namibian desert so very
improbable and what's even more
interesting is that what looks like two
piles of leaves are actually two single
leaves that continue to
grow and pile on top of each other so it
actually is the longest leaves in the
plant kingdom and then they get all
shredded up by the elements of the wind
and the sand over time so this was just
really fascinating to me and so I talked
to a biologist back at the curstyn Bosch
Botanical Garden and cape town cape town
just to get some idea of how this thing
came about and his theory is that if you
travel around the middle Namibia you see
that there are petrified forests all
over the place and they're all old
conifers and so his theory is that tens
of thousands of years ago flooding swept
these trees down from a more northern
part of Africa and then what happened
was the well which iya just adapted and
be--and resulted from that flooding and
in fact if you visit one of these
Petrified Forest you see the old
petrified log and at the top a baby well
with Chia and now and that was around
2,000 years old so now we're getting a
little bit older this is around 2150 and
here in California and California has a
number claim to a number of old things
and there are four trees in the Sequoia
National Park that had been confirmed to
be over 2,000 years old
but the dendrochronologist that I spoke
with there told me that there could be
hundreds more
but there aren't the there's the
resources aren't available to go around
and date all of these trees nor is there
a scientific necessity for it although
he did joke that the trees are all
getting younger every year because their
ages have been so wildly overestimated
in the past this is a favorite of mine
as well this is a Japanese cedar called
Jomon tsuki it's at least two thousand
one hundred and eighty years old and and
this lives on the remote island of
Yakushima in Japan and this tree was
actually the catalyst for this project
so as I mentioned I come from a fine art
background and for years what I was
doing
was making landscape work that deals
with the relationship between humanity
and nature and I was traveling a lot to
do that so I went on this trip to Japan
and I didn't have an agenda other than
to make photographs but people kept
telling me if that was what my interest
was I had to go visit this tree
I mean it's called Jomon tsuki because
it supposedly dates back to the Jomon
era in japanese history which i don't
think is accurate but at any rate i
visited the tree it was on this remote
island and then it was a two day hike to
find the tree once I got there and it
really made an impact on me and it was
actually quite a while later I was doing
the math I thought it was months later
but I realized it was over a year later
that I got the idea to actually bring
together these my interest in art and
science and philosophy into this project
so that's when the light bulb came on if
you will so I began researching and so
so I began researching and one of the
this is one of the the trees that I
found this is the Fortin gall you which
again is around 2,000 years old but
might be much older so these last couple
of examples you see that I have an age
range between two and five thousand
years here and whenever I have that
range in the title what I'm trying to do
is illustrate the fact that the science
might not be done yet or it might not be
that accurate and in some cases local
lore will tend to overestimate the these
organisms far more than what they
actually are so this particular tree is
in a churchyard in Scotland and you can
see it's behind a protective wall and
it's a little sign there that says the
you in case you missed that and it's
actually fairly common if you travel
around the UK to see that their use in
churchyards but when you keep in mind
the 2,000 year time frame time frame
it's actually the use that were there
first and then the churches were built
around them
so back in the US this is in the Malheur
National Forest this is an aerial photo
and if the title searching for our
malaria death ring sounds a bit ominous
it is the our malaria is a predatory
fungus and a kill certain species of
trees in this forest there's also an our
malaria individual arge individual in
michigan and another in sweden but this
is the oldest and the largest and it's
perhaps more benignly known as the honey
mushroom or the humongous fungus so the
our malaria actually kills certain trees
in a circular pattern so that's I got
some maps and some GPS coordinates from
the biologists who work as part of the
Forestry Service and I chartered a plan
and I went looking for the death rings
so I know that the fungus is underground
here but I'm not actually sure if I
captured the the actual death rings but
back on the ground this is actually a
photo of the our malaria invading this
tree so the tree was already dead and
the biologists chopped into it with an
axe and then you see that the this white
material right here it's known as the
mycelium felt of the fungus and what
it's doing is actually slowly strangling
the tree to death so it's a slow and
violent process so it's basically
preventing the flow of water and
nutrients and but this this fungus is
pretty smart if you can call a fungus
smart it actually won't invade these
trees until after they've reached
reproductive maturity so it's basically
ensuring its continued longevity by
making sure it doesn't cut off its own
deplete its own food supply so it's been
doing that for 2,400 years another tree
and this is the Alerus a millenarian and
it's a Patagonian Cypress and logging
has destroyed much of the old old growth
forests in the Valdivia region
and I've found a report of an Allaire
say being up to 3,600 years old but I
have a suspicion that is actually a
felled tree and there actually is
another
elaire say in the Alaric Estero National
Forest that I that I saw and it was
spared and untimely death because when
the loggers came through to chop it down
they found that it was partially hollow
in the middle so it actually is still
standing today just with the big bite
out of its side and then much like the
use and yeomen Sugi this tree this is
the Castagna that gentle Cavalia the
chestnut of a hundred horses and it's in
the two to four thousand range I believe
that it's probably around 3,000 just
because I saw a number of references
that have not actually been able to
translate from the Italian or Sicilian
actually so but actually what's more
easy to track down is the the story that
goes around this tree which is that
supposedly it's a provided shelter for a
queen and a hundred of her knights as
they were traveling to Mount Etna and a
thunderstorm hit so hence the chestnut
of a hundred horses so in terms of trees
the chestnut is really the only other
exception to the evergreen rule so it is
of course deciduous and it was actually
filled with chestnuts you can't really
see it from this shot but it showed no
sign of slowing down in terms of bearing
fruit although you see that it actually
needed some props to keep the branches
up there and I should mention I just
photographed the chestnut back in
September and Malla in the area also
photographed this olive tree and these
trees are really points of pride for
their local communities but you also see
a lot of misinformation circulating in
terms of their ages so I've seen
references for this tree that it's up to
5000 years old but I've seen found no
scientific evidence to back that up
that being said it seems to be the
oldest olive olive tree in the world
I know there been claims that's
something that's actually claimed quite
frequently having the Oh
just olivetree including Israel and
Palestine but we won't go there
so this tree is also actually hollow at
its center and so while other tree's of
its generation were being cut down that
actually saved this tree because they
put it to use it was actually serving as
a chicken coop for quite a long time for
generations actually so those chickens
probably saved its life and this is a
close up of that same tree and so it's
actually still has gainful employment
and the branches from this tree are used
to make Olympic wreaths and the
community is very proud of that um in
fact there's a little Museum and even
hedgerow shaped like the Olympic
insignia and for in the lawn in front of
the tree so but just just but we can
actually use that as a means to put this
into some human perspective and the
first Olympics were said to be held in
70s 776 BCE in Greece so this would have
put that tree at over 200 years at that
time and it's still bearing olives and
in fact I collected some and tried to
get them to sprout but they didn't quite
make it and from the Mediterranean let's
jump to this is Greenland so this is not
an oldest living thing but I wanted to
set the stage for the next organism that
I'm going to show you and so for me
visiting Greenland it was really primal
and remote like nothing I had ever
experienced and it really was like
traveling back in time instead of just
traveling very far north and in fact I
actually got somewhat lost on the other
side of this fjord for a while with
pretty much just myself and my wits
so that was an incredibly humbling
experience and it obviously worked out
in the end
Here I am I just wanted to also note I
was I was actually there meeting some
Danish archaeologists who as an aside
we're doing like a nama tree on some old
norse ruins so using the lichens to help
date the north ruins that they were
studying
the lichen growth so these
archaeologists actually took me fishing
in a glacial stream and they were
literally pulling these foot long or
larger trout out of the water with their
bare hands there were so many of them so
it was really it was just like visiting
the planet at a more innocent time so it
really had an impact on me and the
reason I was in Greenland was to vote I
was looking for lichens what do most
people do when they go to Greenland so I
traveled there with an evolutionary
biologist whom I met on a previous trip
photographing the Siberian
Actinobacteria which we'll get to in a
little bit but what you're looking at
now is a 3,000 year old reso Carbon
Geographic Ammar map like in and there
are reports of these lichens reaching up
to 5,000 years but our estimate was that
this is about 3,000 years based on its
size and so these lichens grow one
centimeter every hundred years so if
that doesn't put human lifespans into a
perspective I don't know what does and
so from the Antarctic to the high desert
in thule and this is sort of the poster
child of the project so this this
strange-looking plant is called the u
Retta
and it what looks like moss covering
rocks is actually a shrub and it's made
up of thousands of branches and at the
end of each branch is a cluster of small
of tiny green leaves that are quite hard
and it's very densely packed together so
much so that you could actually stand on
top of it if you wanted to try that
which I wouldn't recommend because it
also lives at 15,000 feet elevation
which is rather dizzying and this also
happens to be a relative of parsley
which I find coming and there are other
individuals you can see actually you can
see behind there so there actually are a
number of errata plants that that live
in this region and certain other areas
in that high elevation desert in South
America so I actually traveled here with
an expert in the local flora
since since having this photograph up on
my website a number of people have sent
me photos of other you read of plants so
there might be some older ones out there
but just any ideas on what this is this
is actually a baby or Etta so the so on
average they increased about 1.5
centimeters in height a year so that
might help put our large friends into
perspective and the Bristlecone pine so
the talk wouldn't be complete without
talking about the Bristlecone which I
know is near and dear to the hearts of
long now and to me as well
so the Bristlecone pine are you know
most people and think this audience is
probably better educated than most but
most people are aware of the Methuselah
tree but when I spoke with Tom Harlan
was one of the preeminent researchers
and the bristlecones he told me that
back and this was back in 2006 he
actually told me that they had already
discovered a tree that was around 5,000
years old that was using a combination
of core samples and radiocarbon dating
but what was more interesting is that he
told me there was no reason to believe
that we've actually found the oldest
Bristlecone there are thousands of them
which is good news but that really
struck me is this was early on in my
project when I when I made this
photograph and now I think I just had
the sense that of course the science has
been done but it it isn't necessarily
and that was actually sort of a
wonderful door opening so Tom had
suggested that I walk around in in the
White Mountains and in the park there
and to look out for the knobby knees of
these trees so if you're ever looking if
you're ever taking a walk amongst the
bristle bristlecones take a look keep a
lookout for those knobby knees and
you're gonna find some of the oldest
trees and of course they subsist on very
limited nutrients and they're shutting
down non-essential systems and you know
I just had to bring up some recent news
which some of you might be aware of as
well which is not
greatest news but just that the
bristlecones are actually in some danger
right now they are being attacked by the
white pine blister rust as well as the
pine bark beetle which pot which is
actually native but its population has
increased as the climate is getting
warmer but it can't be all bad news I
actually spoke with someone named Jim
peerless who's a forestry expert back
back east and he actually told me that
his father remembers when the blister
rust had invaded the Berkshires back in
the 50s and it was in epidemic
proportions and the state of Connecticut
actually hired his whole family that's a
family business to hike through the
mountains and physically pull up the
wild currant bushes that were host to
the blister rust and that actually got
rid of the problem for over 50 years so
I don't know that removing the blister
rust by hand would be a feasible
approach for helping the bristlecones
but it was nice to hear that this
hands-on approach actually proved
effective in that case um so again we're
in the 5000 year range so I wanted to
you know take a step back and look at
what was going on with with humans
around 5,000 years ago we have the first
Egyptian hieroglyphics work started on
Stonehenge the Mayan calendar starts and
then use of the wheel and cuneiform and
then we're in pre historical times so
and this is just you know and this was
these were all the young ones in my
project so it was sort of interesting to
put into perspective you know we had the
this this was recent news that have
found the the world's oldest shoe and
then of course this door that was found
in Switzerland around 5,000 years old so
I want to jump to nearly 10,000 years so
this is a clonal tree and I'm gonna
describe this a little bit more as we go
but clonal organisms are reaper too
reproducing vegetatively so they're
there DNA is not combining with any
other DNA in order to create a new
organism but instead it's continuing to
do things like send up a new
which which this tree is doing so this
is a nine thousand five hundred and
fifty year old spruce and it lives high
on a plateau in Sweden and it was
actually just discovered a couple of
years ago and like many of the oldest
living things it's kept secret from the
public for its own protection but the
biologists who discovered it told me
that that spindly growth that you see in
the centre is actually relatively new in
fact it might only be around 40 years
old and was and is caused by a change in
the vegetation zone so as it's gotten
warmer this tree is getting taller so
before you know 50 years ago you just
would have seen that mass of branches
here at the bottom persisting four 9950
years so you know sometimes we don't
even have to have direct contact with
these organisms to have a very real
effect on them so back in California
again we have a couple here that are in
the Mojave Desert and this is a clonal
creosote bush that's around 12,000 years
old and you all have seen the creosote
bush they're ubiquitous but these clonal
bushes what they're doing is expanding
outward from an original center and
that's a again it's all in this case all
interconnected still so it's that same
genetically identical individual that
has lived for 12,000 years and it's
growing very very slowly so it's not big
and flashy it's living in a place where
other things have trouble surviving let
alone thriving in this way and it also
has a friend about a mile away I think
they're friends this is the clonal
Mojave yucca it's a little bit older so
it's a little bit over 12,000 years and
you can see behind it there are a couple
younger clones in that same circular
growth pattern and these two organisms
live on Bureau of Land Management land
so that's really not the same thing as
being protected in a national park in
fact this area is actually dedicated to
recreational all-terrain vehicle use so
there's there's fences around but I
think we can do better
so back in Africa when I was tracking
down the Bayeux Bab trees I had the
opportunity to meet with a botanist at
the Botanical Garden in Pretoria and he
told me about what I think is one of the
most fascinating things that I've
learned on this project which is this
phenomena of something they call an
underground forest so this is a bushveld
region and which it's very dry and it's
prone to a lot of fire and so a lot of
organisms there have adapted in various
ways like growing very thick thick skins
if you will but certain species of trees
have actually adapted to go underground
so if this is the crown of the tree and
this is the ground underground so that
whole bulk of the roots and the trunk
and the branches about migrated out of
harm's way and I mean I just thought
that was just absolutely absolutely
remarkable so when a fire roars through
you know it's like the equivalent of
getting your eyebrows in you know it can
recover very easily and this is and
these again are growing clonally sending
out new shoots and the oldest of which
are known to be 13,000 years old and
these were actually discovered not first
by scientists but rather farmers and
people building the roads the people
building the roads thought they were he
was gonna pull this little bush out and
ended up with a kind of mess on their
hands and for the farmers it was a
different problem I'm some of the the
trees are actually poisonous to
livestock so again they tried to pull
them out and couldn't so what they did
was they tend to cut a little branch off
and get it to pull in some water and
then they switch that water out for
poison and just kill it in the ground
so again not exactly getting the respect
that one might hope likewise this is
back in the US this is the box
huckleberry around 13,000 years old
and it lives on private property so I
would the owner was kind enough to let
me come come visit and make some
photographs but it's not currently
protected and this shrub is actually a
relative of the blueberry and there are
some younger clones that are protected
under the Forest Service and this was
first discovered I believe around fifty
years ago so but let's take another jump
in time so what was going on
17,000 years ago well we have the cave
paintings Atlas cow and the closest
human relative going extinct seventeen
thousand years ago that's really not
that long ago in the grand scheme of
things so to jump to a somewhat blank
slide forty-three thousand years ago and
Tasmania there's something on my list
that I haven't photographed yet and it's
a shrub called Kings La Masia our Kings
Holly and it's living in Tasmania on a
very remote area and what's remarkable
about this plant which I hope it will
see next time I'm giving it talk what's
remarkable about this plant is it's the
last known living individual of this
species so it's lost the ability to
reproduce sexually because there's only
one of them so it's just if you see
other examples of this plant it's
actually cuttings from it and it's just
continuing to survive 43,000 years on
its own and again so to put this into a
little bit more perspective anatomically
modern humans originated in Africa about
200,000 years ago and started to spread
between 50,000 and a hundred thousand
years ago so we're digging a little
deeper here and I want to look at that
fifty to a hundred
actually let's jump to 280 thousand
years I mean this is actually I think
one of the best examples on how to
understand what a clonal colony is so
what looks like a forest here could
actually be considered one tree and what
I mean by that is that each tree that
you see in this forest is actually a
stem coming up from one continuous root
system and this is in Utah and it's been
living there for 80,000 years and so in
theory it could be immortal it could
just continue to send up new shoots it
also happens to be male so this is
actually this is actually another shot
of Pando just to help describe the the
the size of it a little bit more so what
do you see in the back here way at the
back is the original colony and what you
see here is this huge swatch in the
middle that the Forest Service actually
cut down in an attempt to stimulate new
growth but what happened was the deer
came in and ate all the saplings so what
did they do they did it again but they
put a fence up and so now they actually
did so this is the new growth and then
behind again behind it is that original
colony and that's actually extends back
behind where I made the photograph and
so when you arrive at panda you actually
see a sign there that says wood
available to free wood for firewood so
the this again was a fairly recent
discovery believe around 20 years ago
and I spoke to the scientists who
discovered it who does not feel it's
gotten the attention it deserves in fact
its primary claim to fame is that it was
once a postage stamp
so from 80,000 back to a hundred
thousand years ago this was one of the
things that I photographed this
September as well in the Mediterranean
um this is a clonal colony of seagrass
that is thought to be a hundred thousand
years old so this is actually living and
protected when UNESCO protected waters
that extend between the islands of
Formentera and bisa of all places but
it's actually threatened now by some
invasive algae that's towed its way in
on cruise ships but I was lucky enough
to have the opportunity to actually join
the scientists doing their field
research which they do once a year and
they study these plots of the sea grass
and and carefully count how many shoots
are in these individual plots and they
actually discovered the age quite by
accident so they found that in two plots
that were extended by a considerable
distance actually had the identical
genetic makeup so you never know what
you're gonna find which brings us to
what is most likely the oldest living
thing on the planet this is an image
that I made in a lab at Niels Bohr
Institute and Copenhagen of the Siberian
Actinobacteria which is between 400,000
and 600,000 years old so half a million
years old and this was discovered by a
team of planetary biologists who went to
Siberia and took a core sample into the
permafrost just to see what they could
find so they were looking for clues to
life on other planets and they ended up
discovering this bacteria which you know
you hear about old bacteria and ice
cores in Antarctica all the time but
what sets this apart is that it's
actually doing DNA repair below freezing
so what that means is that it's been
living and growing for half a million
years so again they didn't know what
they were looking for but they ended up
making a very important discovery and
this was only a few years ago again
and I was fortunate enough I think I was
actually one of the first people that
got to attempt to make a photograph of
this bacteria because I ended up quite
by accident meeting one of the
biologists this is a team from MIT
working with with niels bohr
i happened to be at a New Year's Eve
party in Brooklyn and somebody said you
have to go talk to this biologist and
sure enough she was on the team that
helped discovered the bacteria so again
it's just been a kind of remarkable
where the information is coming from so
um here we are the oldest living thing
in the planet but it's also one of the
most vulnerable because if the
permafrost melts it won't survive so my
research is not complete yet this is a
map that I put together showing
locations of all of the oldest living
things which by the way is a fluid list
things a number of things have been
discovered since I started this project
and occasionally something is debunked
and removed the blue flags here
represent things that I've already
photographed so you can see I forgotten
got it around and then the red flags
represent the things that I have still
yet to get to so I think I have about
two more years left on this project give
or take for this phase of it as any at
any rate but I do feel like this is
probably life's work and nothing that I
planned on giving up so you also see
there are oldest living things on every
continent so two of the things that I'm
most of the trips that I'm most excited
for our Australia and Tasmania for that
Kings La Masia which you saw as well as
some other clonal organisms as well to
check out those stromatolite s-- and
then probably what I'm most excited for
is the chance to go to Antarctica where
there's five thousand-year-old Moss
banks living on the Antarctic Peninsula
so this is a complete surprise to find
that out so I'm definitely looking
forward to that so
I just I'm at the point where I'm trying
to look at what kind of lessons can we
draw from all of this data I mean as I
said you know this project hasn't been
done before so this is really a sketch
so it's not it's not entirely accurate
but I wanted to illustrate some of the
patterns that I see emerging one is slow
and steady growth as opposed to fast and
furious and you know of course there are
exceptions to every rule that I'm going
to share with you because we do as you
saw some of the largest organisms are
also included on this list but many of
them are incredibly slow growing and a
number of them endure extreme stress in
fringe environments so they're surviving
cold or drought or very high elevations
and as with calorie restricted diets
some of them have a very limited supply
of nutrients so you know I looked at a
few criteria here including altitudes
the ones that are circled there the five
five thousand plus feet in altitude and
then a few different climatic regions
climatic regions excusing but I've
basically been a bit of a one-woman
research team here for a while now so
I'm hoping that researchers will start
to pick up and run with some of these
themes because again I started this from
the perspective as making an art project
but after five years of work I can say
this the oldest living things in the
world are a record and celebration of
our past their call to action in the
present and they're a barometer of our
future and personally I think some of
the best work regardless of its
discipline excuse me
will answer some questions but it will
also ask several more and this project
certainly asked more questions than I
can prop that I could possibly answer
but for me it's involved a long look
back and a broad look out from my
initial area of comfort and expertise
and my hope is that these organisms will
continue to be around to enjoy the first
times of the 10,000 year clock thank you
[Applause]
we have secret tears Laraine Palmer
asked to do Redwoods reproduce clonally
and if so who's what's the oldest
redwood tree ring well let's break that
question down I do not believe that any
of the redwoods are reproducing clonally
I could be wrong the redwoods in general
are not quite as old as the giant
sequoia so of course they are related
there is I believe one redwood at least
that meets that 2,000 year mark Coppock
says an argument can be made that the
first amoeba is still alive have you
considered microscopic animal life and
bacteria presumably in a sensor the
original one is still around
yeah it's an interesting question I mean
I think that I've been in creating the
scope of the project one thing that I
was trying to differentiate between is
what organisms are very primitive and
still maintain those primitive
structures versus organisms that have
truly been around for that full 2000
plus timespan so an amoeba I'm not sure
if it would meet that criteria fair
enough getting more technical question
from Rupert Carlsen how do the oldest
organisms avoid cancer how do they avoid
the hayflick limit telomeres and all
that and does every cell contains
elevators and you know the kind of
things that we're studying at aging in
humans when we go to borrow some of
these genes what are we looking for what
are their techniques of staying old well
I wish I could answer that
I mean I think that's actually the one
of the questions that this project asks
is how do they do it so again I actually
invite scientific research for about to
back up but to create to start to see
what patterns might emerge from looking
at these different organisms because
again you have you know we see some
groupings we have the the Tuda roughly
five thousand year group and then we
make a big jump to ten to thirteen
thousand and then another really big
jump from that forty three thousand
which is sort of on its own up to half a
million so it seems like there's some
something to decode there but again I
didn't actually learn that at a art
school are you very in the direction of
more art or more biology as time goes
forward do you think well I like that
they're together in this project and I
really think that they're inseparable in
terms of this work one wouldn't be
possible without the other I could make
landscape work which I do but it
wouldn't be I wouldn't contain the same
impact it wouldn't have the same message
and the titles of the work are actually
part of the work I consider them
inseparable so that scientific
information is vital to the the
overarching message of the project yeah
I like the now reminded that with just
one photograph was untitled and it's
just rocks and that yes exactly so a lot
of my landscape work is I would say
landscapes that are dealing with
philosophy which is a little bit more
abstract than this project so here you
are interacting with the scientists and
it it looks like you've encountered
something like what we've encountered
with the Rosetta project for you know we
sort of went to linguists and said we
want to collect all the languages in the
world in one place and basically found
that that was academically not a subject
yes and so you're collecting
this whole category of long-lived
organisms I gather was not a subject yes
so now it is and you're talking to these
scientists and are are they getting
interested in this and are they
connecting with each other across the
various sub disciplines and whatnot
I would say they're starting to and
that's actually been one of the most
satisfying experiences I've had is when
I get to say like hey do you know about
this research in Pretoria and I get to
connect some biologists who in turn talk
so I'd say on the you know very basic
level there are some conversations that
have been facilitated through the
project I hope that there will be more
but that being said I mean really I
think there is this tendency to
specialize which I completely understand
and is necessary although I have to tell
you one little story when I was in
photographing the fungus in Oregon the
biologists were actually making fun of
another biologist who wasn't with us
because she only studied part of the
fungus and they thought that was really
nerdy
[Laughter]
which nostril is they saying your nose
in it well it cursed me you got two more
years to go on this project I'll bet
it's more than that but so but at some
point you're gonna declare this is
finished in the ears book and here's the
slideshow and what I would love to see
at that point is a conference that
somebody here might sponsored that would
bring together all the scientists that
you've encountered all this time in one
place at one time where they would not
only sort of enjoy and celebrate and
tell stories about you know when they
took you out into the desert of whatever
but actually have a conference on
longevity in organisms absolutely that's
something I've thought about as well and
I think it would be absolutely
invaluable opportunity to start to
facilitate a conversation between people
that didn't necessarily even consider
that this work was happening on the
other side of the world might be really
relevant and just to open up this idea
that there could be an area of this new
area of study and there's a lot of work
to be done you mentioned there was XO
biologists who turned up one of these
creatures I guess was the very old soil
bacterium say more about what they're up
to you the implications yeah I mean the
famous problem with exobiology is it's a
science without a subject so was this
the work around for them or it could be
I mean I think the hope the hope is that
something here will actually prove
valuable in understanding that once we
do mm-hmm
when we do make that kind of discovery
because one of the member when the
Viking landing or Lander first went to
Mars and so on they were kind of digging
in in adding water and seeing everything
grew basically doing things that would
recognize life that we already knew
about and some scientists were saying
how boring let's try to find a way to
discover
life that we don't know about and how
strange can I get and sort of since then
there's been more and more science that
shows that life can get very strange
indeed yes do you get a sense from these
characters too that there's more
weirdness to be found absolutely yes I
mean one of the things that I've thought
about that I've learned a little bit
about that haven't fully researched it's
the idea of extremophiles right so I
think that would just be fascinating
subject matter and well o ffice uma
bleed showed that shirt in an extreme
situation this was how Bristlecone Pines
were discovers you may know the story is
that there was this guy who's been
studying I think limber pines and
realized that the ones that had the most
growth rings skinny little trees
nevertheless were at tree line and so he
thought okay extreme situation tree line
situation that's where you find the
oldest trees and then he started
exploring tree lines all over the West
and discovered Bristlecone Pines and
National Geographic story happened and
it's now we're building a clock there so
obviously yeah so extremophiles I mean
partly extremophiles are what turned up
thieves here's a proper word archaea the
really most seemingly ancient form of
bacteria rather different than the other
not so of ancient bacteria and so are
you gonna be hanging out in hot springs
and under glaciers and stuff like that
it's possible one of the things that
caught my attention recently was the
discovery of the carbon breathing
microbes in Antarctica I mean it just it
really that kind of blew my mind okay
that sounds like a way to solve climate
change because they breathe they breathe
carbon that sounds like they're the air
captures it's called what do they do
with the carbon once they get it I'm
actually not sure enough to call in an
expert any experts Carbon breathing Mike
yeah crowdsourcing and carbon breathing
bacteria
wrong crowd next question
Sally says what a great talk you're here
and then quotes hmm 9550 year-old tree
would you briefly speak about how one
would get such a precise age PS comment
when you said like anonyme are liking
like a nama tree like a llama tree I
heard like a nominee the study of
Facebook which also baby coming in 9,000
years but okay how do these precise ages
come out of these things
um so in this case it was actually
radiocarbon dating of samples at the
site and there were where other where
there were other trees that have said
that aren't actually alive right now
that dated back even further so a lot of
times with these really old things that
you're seeing a combination of
radiocarbon dating and then observing
them over long periods of time so you're
measuring a growth rate and then
extrapolating the data and then these
these different methods often proves to
be checks and balances to see how
accurate you are so looking at
dendrochronology and radiocarbon dating
for instance a question I realized from
Adrian coffer that I also had is how are
the clonal organisms dated how so that's
a similar that was actually that
combination the same same answer applies
they're all done a little bit
differently and I should mention that
what I try to do is find the scientific
papers and then in turn track down the
actual sciences scientists who were
doing the research and so sometimes you
can actually see them in the field
making their notations and pulling out
rulers and that sort of thing so it's
it's a combination of things but you
know in some cases these are educated
guesses I think I know the answer this
one's from anonymous why do people big
red letters white people like and tend
to make things older than they really
are what about the olive tree over here
thousand-year-old olive tree you know
lady
what are you doing why do you think it's
exactly what the docents and the clock
are gonna do people make up stories that
are you know the bigger and battery you
can make it bigger tip you're gonna get
from the tourists I guess so you nobody
ever says well this is the second-oldest
tree no I fact if you if you google
oldest living tree you'll see including
amongst the scientists who know better
mmm Loreen Palmer says what would you
say that since we know so little about
the sea environment that you may find
major new additions in your project list
coming from the oceans is that research
goes forward yeah that seems entirely
possible I mean especially with research
around the sea vents but again we're
talking extremophiles there which seems
to be another project perhaps but I
actually found out about the corals late
in the game so I knew about the seagrass
for a while that was difficult to track
down the researchers because that's such
a new research but a biologists contact
me contacted me just a couple of weeks
ago to tell me about this cold water
coral that is off the coast of
Scandinavia that he said was around
between four and five thousand years old
but it's in frigid water so it really it
requires this a submersible device and
remote imaging there's a quest in quest
question here
are there any older organisms that
you've heard about set out to find and
just couldn't get to them I think I've
actually made it all of them not that
there haven't been obstacles certainly
the well which gia for instance I had
been talking to the desert Research
Centre there for about six months and
when I arrived in Namibia they sent me
an email and said oh yes we have left
the country for her Ohio
I actually ended up tracking finding a
local naturalist self-taught who found
the well with Geo there was a wealth of
misinformation about it say a little bit
about that sort of the local folks
versus the remote academic folks do they
connect do they have completely
different knowledge domains what goes on
I think well this sort of ties into the
question about why is everything so much
older in these cases he told stories
there's you know folklore about how the
well which he will come and eat you as a
child if you're bad he was doing things
like sticking meat thermometers in the
sand and saying that was it was a
hundred and sixty degrees out
so his methodology was questionable but
it was interesting but you know the well
which is actually the national plan of
Namibia so it's something that's really
beloved Chris Lombardi asks an
interesting question talk about
humongous fungus what about that largest
organism the mushroom under Michigan
yeah that's a it's the same type of
fungus but the one in Oregon is actually
larger and older say again about size
how big I don't think I said okay I
don't want to be you're hiding I
actually I'm sorry I don't actually
remember the size of it offhand I don't
want to misspeak well there's a sort of
question comment from it looks like mary
hunter um comment on your decisions
should not provide a sense of size and
scale in your photographs yes that was
definitely a choice that I made in part
for a couple of reasons one is that I
sort of think of these images as
portraits of these plants and so I
definitely I'm approaching the
photography from some artistic
standpoint and you know there's a lot of
mystery involved in finding tracking
these things down finding out what they
were to begin with and I wanted to sort
of share the mystery of that experience
a little bit so I didn't set out to
create National Geographic photos or
scientific photos with you know what
all the measurements down the side so
I'd perfectly that's why I was thinking
of them as a portrait that hopefully
that you can get into the spirit of what
these organisms are but then balance
that against the scientific information
and you know I welcome you to search on
these other facts so it's it's
interesting but you know I also had to
limit it to limit my scope of what I was
doing in order to well there you are I
mean you've hiked two days and the weird
country and you finally got into the
organism and there it is you're making
multiple exposures we're seeing just one
of them do you ever have have a
temptation just put a meter stick in the
picture was one exposure so for this you
know not for the emotional viewers but
the scientific viewers I do sometimes
have points of reference in the photo so
and it is something that I actually do
discuss with the biologists especially
if I'm there in the field with them so
occasionally on some of my images we'll
end up in reports in which case we'll
discuss the size and scale of them but I
just consider that a separate purpose so
I could also imagine in that for example
of the web version that that if they
exist you know that there's a screamer
an overlay that one could drop on it
would give scale absolutely I'm
definitely not opposed in any sense of
everybody having this information and I
look forward to a time when I can create
a digital version because I you know I
would like to provide something where
people can explore in a nonlinear
fashion through whatever Avenue that
interests you so if you're interested
and you know we want to look at deserts
you want to look at a certain elevation
if you want to look based on age that
you could explore in all these different
ways so hopefully that is to come
Brooks raises it raises a question it
says which are the greater threats to
these old living things climate change
in a setter or a lack of awareness of
them or what and the temptation was is
when showing wildlife pictures which you
are is
and to sort of carry away the worry that
of we're not going to see these things
again long live it as they are it will
be terrible to loose them because of
this that or the other thing and on the
one hand that's sort of an easy way to
end the evening everybody goes out
worried about something on the other
hand one could say these are very tough
creatures killing them as no Zinj
so you know where are where do we come
out on that but responsible optimism you
know I can't answer scientifically you
know what's the greatest threat and it's
different for different organisms but I
think there's a lot to be learned from
them and a lot of them like back to the
fungus for instance that doesn't doesn't
take its prey until after its reproduced
I mean these are pretty resilient things
these are really or the actually the the
clonal colony of aspen trees actually
moves slightly up and down the mountain
based on climate so as it's getting
warmer it's getting it's moving its the
grip tends to have more growth towards
the northern slope where it's more we're
at better suits its its growth so these
things are they're doing subtle but very
important things that you know they are
they want to say I don't want to impose
consciousness on them but they want to
survive no one gets a sense with you
know Brett if climate change is gradual
enough that some of these clone set of
Aspen's is marching gradually north as
well as uphill creosote you've been to a
creosote place I've heard creosote
described as the the most vile
sort of
desert gobbling plant there is that
where creosote is nothing else is or
wants to be is that what you found out
there well I mean it definitely was the
the dominant life-form where I was I
mean and then you know sometimes you why
do you such a good example its predatory
it's something that the forest the
Forestry Service there is actually
trying to contain I mean they're not
going to kill it but at the same time
it's something that they don't want to
spread and invasive species again when
we were talking about with Bristlecone
pine and even the the seagrass the
hundred thousand year old seagrass was
getting innovated is in being invaded by
foreign algae and you can see it in
different places I didn't share this
evening but you know you can see where
it's actually taking over of Kevin's
question that made me jumped is he's a
photographer why do you still use film
instead of digital so almost all the
images that you saw tonight where I'm
shot with film with the exception of the
underwater shots and the microscopy and
in part you know I still make prints you
know i exhibit the work in art galleries
and they're they're quite large they're
40 by 50 and I shoot medium format film
and then I scan the negatives actually
so I'm using both analog and digital
processes for it medium format to a
quarter to five six seven format it's a
rangefinder camera sort of looks like a
big like hard to carry two days is happy
yes I've spent some time the film I
still feel from an artistic standpoint
is just it it's more beautiful the pen
product is oh we've some photographers
in the audience
I I think that the quality of it the
quality of the light I always shoot with
natural light I never use flash and I
think that film still is just captures
the the but the tonal range and the
technical sides of it as well as
aesthetically has a warmer look to it
you might expect somebody was looking
for really old things to be kind of
traditional it's being a witch filling
him dances how's your perception of deaf
evolved as a result however you nobody
here is a hundred thousand or expects to
be so you know death looms is that come
into all of this is you're looking at
these things I would definitely say that
my perception of time is different
because I have something then to anchor
to that I think it's really hard to hold
on to this idea of deep time or anything
beyond the five minutes from now the
five minutes ago
you know physiologically it's difficult
for us our brains don't want to do that
and I think that by doing this research
I start I am continually pulled back
into this deeper timeline so it
definitely affects my sense of longevity
in general the human lifespan
that being said I'm not thinking like
I'm about to turn a hundred so yes no
sir
well in a way the what the picture the
idea that got me was the you tree that
attracted a churchyard around it now the
question in my mind is you know whether
there was this big you tree and it's
time to make a church let's build it
there with a big you tree is or is that
they there was a set of yew trees and
okay that one will be in the churchyard
and we'll build the churchyard and then
all the other you trees get cut down to
don't one of the churchyard doesn't what
do you think came first on that oh I
mean I think that it is true that once
they were in the church I believe my my
understanding of the sequence was
you know there were the yew trees were
there they chose to build these churches
where the yew trees were and then over
time a number of those other use have
been cut down and then they in turn
became the ones that survived today were
protected by by the churches so here's
the link to death graveyards or famously
places where field biologists go to find
out what the landscape was like back
before cattle and everything else
because the cattle the graveyards are as
fans nobody likes to see a cow on a
grave and as a result you know the tall
grass prairie or whatever it is is there
in the graveyard if it's been loved and
protected over time and what does that
say it says that churchyard there's some
whenever the sacred and some even modest
sense meets the landscape the kind of
organisms you're talking about feel at
home there and vice versa
so maybe that's your next project
graveyards to the world could be I
actually saw firsthand when I was in
Greenland the the archaeologist that I
was camping with dug out a Norse
gravesite and every day another skeleton
was emerging it was at this lookout
point and I mean that was a really
remarkable experience like talking about
the history and these people that
actually tried to settle in this
incredibly inhospitable climate and
that's the area that eventually they
failed and it's one of the stories in
the collapse
well here's four organisms that don't
collapse thank you for coming thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you